in california yes
gentlemen we are live all right david
says we're live we're live by the way
david it's good to have you back okay
thank you thank you don't you tell us
where you were at go ahead buddy i went
to playa del carmen so he starts off
roll that regular
and then he goes straight up with the
axe and by the way i gotta tell you guys
sammy uh we have sammy double gravano
here with us today sammy thank you for
being on the podcast my pleasure
we're going to talk about mafia states
of america and we're going to talk about
a lot of other things that's going on
uh in uh different stories but my
shower here in the office i'm begging
the building to fix my shower to be warm
water okay
i go in there this is the fourth time
the plumber i'm right now it's a public
announcement if the plumber's listening
please yes
i'm telling you give me some hot water i
go in there every time i go in the
carolinas like no they fixed it i go and
i scream like a little girl i'm like
loud off the top of my lungs but i have
to start it with a cold shower sometimes
i go hot then i go cold i thought it was
very important for the world to know
about this the fact that my water is
still cold so sam tell caroline tell
mickey please let's fix this [ __ ] so how
cold is it good it's so cold that it
wakes me up it's great i don't mind it i
mean i come right after the gym but it
wakes me up so i'm awake right now so
that's that loud girlish scream we hear
yeah i can't scream like that okay but
it's a manly scream like that so yeah
anyways
at least you look good it's a shame
because we all know what happens to a
man in a cold shower
they feel more confident their
confidence goes up i don't know about
that same thing that happens in the pool
the water was gone yeah two minutes into
the podcast i just got out the water i
just got another one that's a cassandra
reference
oh my gosh so sammy um
since we announced mafia states of
america trailer the couple trailers
that's come out
tell us what are your thoughts the three
days we spent together uh while we did
the interview and what are you hearing
from the market what are people telling
you i know your podcast is crushing it
uh you got some big projects coming uh
soon as well which i'm sure you know
the followers are gonna know about but
tell us what's what's happened ever
since we sat down with you and michael
uh with the mafia states of america
well a lot of things all my following
everybody's asking me when it comes out
when it's going to come out and all this
other stuff
so
i tell them soon and uh
but
everything is going well
and we're getting a lot of calls from
everybody different companies different
people from all over the place
and um i think the three days we spent
there with the interview some of them
were a little rough i think
i got a little excited a couple of times
but uh i think it went well
i think it went very well i thought
there was a great team put together my
team came down they loved it they
enjoyed it
i mean uh
i think i have a different different
image of
michael really yeah i do i have a
different image of him
you know meeting his family and and him
and
i think he's a lot more honest than i
thought originally
and
i got to like
very interesting did you think that was
going to be the case because when you
and i talked the first time for a couple
hours you were like there's no way in
the world i'm going to do this
and then a couple years later you ended
up doing it your expectation going in
versus what ended up happening do those
two align or did you think it was going
to be slightly different
i didn't know what it was going to be
like i'll tell you the truth michael's a
racketeers no question about it he was a
money maker for the family
he did that russian thing he said he
started he actually started
but uh the russians did it they used us
it was a very intelligent move that they
did
and they came to us with this [ __ ]
protect us and do this and do that
they came to us for one reason we had
connections all over the city of new
york
we could put them in hundreds of gas
stations with their guests
and their scam and they gave us money
but they gave us that [ __ ] story
were scared take care of us
they didn't need us to take care of us
they just needed us to get gas stations
so there was a lot of stories and he was
one of the first people they went to
i think his father's reputation and name
made them go to him
and uh he was very successful with it
but like we talked about in the in the
thing i think i'm a gangster and a
little bit of a racketeer i think people
agree with that
and he's more of a
marketeer
which is not a shame there's no shame to
that but and i think he believes in a
lot of things his religion
i questioned that a couple of times
but i think uh
you know some people change their life
and believe it
some people don't
but i think he's
told the truth so i changed my mind a
little bit this whole thing that you
know uh we have a clip that we'll show
here in a minute
uh with rudy giuliani
and there's a part where i ask rudy
about
do people change you know all this other
stuff and he says certain things about
michael he says certain things about
gotti and then he says certain things
about you about people changing but and
we'll get into that here in a minute but
the question i have for you is
there seems to be
and i know i don't know if we got into
this or not there seems to be a certain
level of pride
to say
i'm a gangster versus a racketeer in
your world like we're not in your world
we don't know your world but in your
world how is a gangster scene how is a
racketeer scene in the streets it's
almost like if i'm in a military you
know i wonder is it like infantry versus
support what does that look like
racketeer against gangster
that's a great analogy i mean uh
infantry to uh versus support
you know when you're in the infantry
you're going out and you're putting
yourself on the front lines and there's
somebody in the way in the back
supporting you they all deserve respect
they're all part of it yeah but i mean
the main guy on the front lines you got
to give him a lot of respect he's the
guy taking the bullets giving them
i mean he's the guy who's making them
happen so you got to respect him a
little bit more than the guy in the back
but
they're all part of it so i never looked
at it and when i was in the military as
well i never looked at somebody who was
in the back
that he was less than me but
he was in the back i was in the trenches
and i really wasn't in the trenches i
was in the infantry but i was on
communication so
in the back we set up a tent
where they communicate with the front
lines and back and forth i'm the schmuck
who ran back and forth to the front line
to talk with the guy who's got the radio
or
what there was problems so i'm i'm back
and forth
so i knew what it was to sit in the back
and i knew it was i'd be sitting on the
front lines i'd rather sit in the back a
little bit
but
you have bullets [ __ ] flying around
where was this exactly
uh in training okay training yeah i
never went to vietnam for vietnam this
is for okay gotcha yeah i was in durham
event and i bought but i never went
there you needed a a full year i only
had eight months left so they wouldn't
ship you out
so and then they asked me when i go to
the va
did you have boots on the ground
uh
yeah i did in bensonhurst brooklyn i had
boots on the ground not in vietnam
you know he went to vietnam except he he
was in vietnam to party not yeah it was
a great time well after the war was over
yeah yeah yeah
early 2000s yeah
different story different stories
so
so so racketeering and gangster like
when when guys that listen to your
podcasts or guys that listen to
interviews and they're in the world
maybe they were an associate maybe they
were amazing i'm not even talking about
the copos underboss or anybody that's
you know had a rank
those who were an associate or those who
were made men
how do they look at visually like i'm
really curious how do they look at a
gangster
versus a racketeer if they if they
walked up to a racketeer and it's an
earner as big as sammy as big as michael
the kind of money that he was making do
they look at him and did they say wow
this guy's making money for a lot of us
so respect for that and then do they
look at the gangster and say i better
not cross this guy what is that level of
mindset in your world not our world in
your world
well to put it in your world how do you
look when you go in a room and there's a
pit bull
and there's a poodle
what do you think and how do you feel
you're saying a racketeer is a poodle
well compared to a pit bull
he's a pool
yes
so
that's an interesting analogy to say the
least i didn't think i don't really have
a comment other than that's interesting
well i mean you know i'm a gangster
you're a racketeer that's what i just
learned because i make the money and you
deal with other stuff yeah well a pit
bull bites right so you're gonna have
well you know i'm gonna be a little more
cautious than this i got you poodle and
the pit bull you know the poodle makes
money at shows shows and and and you got
to respect that he's won medals and you
could sell his little puppies and stuff
like that for big money and so you
respect both of them you love both of
them they're dogs yeah semiconductors
one's a little more dangerous than the
other one can can the gangsters
do they need to coexist meaning do you
need to have racketeers and gangsters
can you just have gangsters can you just
no you do you gotta have a yin yang kind
of a thing how does it work
it's
listen we respect the entire thing if
you burnt that saint in your hand and
you became a made guy we respect you no
matter what
we respect the life
so we respect whatever you are somebody
proposed you to become a friend of ours
and we respect that if we don't respect
that we could die we can't raise our
hands to one another i can't raise my
hands to a guy who's a racketeer and say
i'm a tough guy and he's not i thought
[ __ ] just don't work
everybody has equal respect david is
that mike on
is that mike on no is that mike on kai
it was on now you turned it off okay
good okay that's good i'm hearing stuff
okay uh excellent did that answer your
question for you that racket versus
gangster i want to make sure that he was
the reason why we're asking this
question is because adam's thinking
about being a gangster and we're trying
to hold him back from doing it because
he wants to i don't think he is
convinced
he doesn't want to do la cosa nostra he
talks about like kosher no stress it's
what he wants to do that's appropriate
yeah he could uh go to uh uh you know a
jewish deli and
and hit it up thank you but you've been
you said very quite candidly last night
that you got along very well with jews
and the italians and the jews coexisted
and you guys did things together would
you expound upon that absolutely
absolutely i always did
in bensonhurst brooklyn when i was a kid
it was predominantly an italian
jewish neighborhood we had a house my
mother and father and us in the middle
on both sides there was three houses
attached on both sides there was jewish
families
and we had a tremendous respect i told
stories a long time ago my friends would
break my balls you're jewish
they would call you jewish yeah you're a
jew i said i'm not i'm italian what are
you talking about they said in the house
when we put up the christmas lights and
the window there was the hanukkah lights
the menorah the menorah the shamash was
right here the leader right so
i went in and asked my father
why are we putting candles in the window
that are jewish people think we're
jewish
he said because our neighbors the
holiday is very similar and respected
the neighbors they're jewish i put the
menura in the window
and i learned things like that when i
shove a little snow for my own house i
did it for them
and
they always took care of me that fish
they would call me in sammy come in my
house they bought they knew i had a fish
tank they would buy me fish i always had
great relationships with jewish people
sammy what's the story about the the
jewish community i talked to myron
sugarman i don't know if you uh
uh know the name myron sugarman or not
no i had a month and he was a
he was a a jewish gangster he calls
himself the last jewish gangster and he
was telling stories about the jewish uh
mob back in the days how tough they were
how strong they were and partly he
talked about how they trained italians
because they were one of the first that
what do you know you're a history guy
what do you know what the history of the
jewish mob and the affinity with the
italian mob did they try was there a
training
going on was there some kind of a do you
know how you're talking about maya
lansky yeah
they were very powerful in the mob
mother corporate it was mostly jews
say that one more time murder
incorporated the shooters were mostly
jewish interesting why was that
i don't know ask lucky luciano when you
see him okay but uh lucky luciano was
completely close with maya lansky and a
lot of jewish
gangsters he grew up with them he liked
them they were around him and they were
tough
i mean bugsy siegel
these people were tough people murder
incorporated there was a bunch of them
well it comes down
the actual history of it comes from the
original immigration the jews were the
first real wave of immigrants in lower
manhattan and then you know we talked
about this with the irish corned beef on
st patrick's day is actually the jews
teaching the irish how to cure their
meat there was no refrigeration they
couldn't afford it so it's kind of the
same thing in the in the early american
you love this word zeitgeist the the
eastern europeans and the jews were the
first wave of
uh immigrants and then the italians and
the irish we were the second wave so we
kind of learned from them coming over
here
and even when i was in the military
there was a few jewish guys i knew
and they were from new york and we used
to travel with the car back and forth
and
one of the guys his mother would make me
sandwiches
she heard my name was sammy she must
have thought i was a jew she made me say
well she made me with this jewish salt
on top of the
fat the fat
on top of the sandwich it was delicious
and
she liked me up until she saw a cross on
my neck i think that didn't like me no
more but
i had another guy
fellman
teddy fellman
when we got out he owned the um
an employment center and he hired me and
my friends got us jobs and places and so
i always got along with jews so you had
a good relationship i saw you do an
interview with a
bunch of black guys i think it was like
an iheart media i don't i don't recall
and they were asking you how you or
italians got along with the blacks in
your neighborhood do you recall that
interview
um unless you're talking about gangster
chronicles i don't know what it was
called but it was you in a room uh they
were asking you about relations with uh
how you got along with african americans
i always got along good with them
you know
especially in prison
i got along very well
i'm not racist i'm not anything like
that i don't walk around like in prison
thinking my [ __ ] don't stink so i had
good relationships with people
um
i went to gyms i used to spa and i
worked out with black guys and
things so i never had a problem with
black guys you told the story about when
you were in the army that
uh
they were in line given the food
and they were they were calling you boy
and they were like you said the most
racist people were in south carolina at
this point in your life well i i didn't
i didn't pick south carolina i was in
carolina port jackson yeah fort jackson
south carolina
i knew what racist was
in new york i mean i knew what it is
growing up i said when i went down there
and i went to fort jackson south
carolina i saw it in a whole different
light
i never
in new york i never went around where a
black guy couldn't go into the same
bathroom
but down there they had that
so it was really late 60s when was this
in the 60s 64 i got in the 60s yeah
so it was really heavy down there now
probably not
legally but the people some of the
people and i had trouble with a couple
guys walking on the line
and we were serving he came from the
bronx this black guy
and i heard him call him boy and this
and that
i know he wouldn't like that
i looked at him but it didn't seem to
bother him then he did that with me
and uh
then he
had told me whip it on me boy
you know and i was putting the stuff in
the in his tray and stuff i had that
long metal spoon
it started dripping over and i stopped
and he threw it on the table
and he says when i tell you whip it on
me i'll tell you when to [ __ ] stop
i was stunned
so i just whacked him right in the front
of me
and then the black guy jumped over the
counter because the other his friend hit
me with the train the black guy jumped
out and we were fighting a couple of
them
and then
the mps came we were like arrested
and
the guy that had mp was a black guy and
he looked at me
and he says you like helping black
people but he thought i jumped in to
help him
it was the other way around
gotcha but i wasn't going to tell him
that so i said well that's the way it is
in new york
and he winked at me so i knew i wasn't
in trouble
and uh
but we
we never were able to serve anymore they
put us in the back we were peeling
potatoes all the time no more spoons for
you no more spoons
it's tough to hurt somebody with a
potato yeah yes you gotta throw it at
them versus right and you're not on the
line so you're in the back with a big
drum and peeling potatoes all [ __ ]
day long
so i i never had a problem my
granddaughter is biracial
so
i never had a problem you know i'm doing
a video now i was in
prison and i was with a
a biker
this guy mark
he had
long long hair coming down a full beard
he looked like
just he looked like he had all hair his
whole face everything you could hardly
see his face
real racist guy
and uh i'm in the cell with him
the unit manager was black a black woman
and she said i'm going to put you in the
cell with him
he's
i'm going to move you as soon as i can
but put up with it
so she knew he was a problem he's a
white guy a white guy a lot of heroines
look like a [ __ ] uh monkey
and uh so
we have
conversations and stuff and
you know he sees a program with a black
man a white woman he wants to change his
channel he wants to do this he wants to
do that
so i said leave it alone
then this the thing every time i got up
i stepped on potato chips pretzels he
was real dirty
that was my first argument i said bro we
got to live in here clean it i don't
want this [ __ ] on the floor
so
then one day
when i wanted to watch a program
and he didn't want it he says
i know why
you allowed
us because your daughter
she likes black people right
i said shut your [ __ ] mouth bro i
told you to stop with the racist [ __ ]
he carried on then he said yeah yeah a
little [ __ ] baby
i hit him so [ __ ] hard we fought all
night long because it was after we let
go and you're in the same cell as this
guy same cell we [ __ ] bashed the [ __ ]
out of each other all night one night
holy [ __ ] got up the next day it was a
spanish guy steve over the next so
sammy what the [ __ ] were you doing bro
so what do you think i was doing bro i
was [ __ ] fighting all night
my lip is hanging
everything's [ __ ] but he was all
[ __ ] up he went to the unit manager
and he told her
she called me in
and uh she said what happened
i said none
she said nothing
you're all caught up
the guy told me that you had a fight
with him so i said listen not a fight
so she says he said racial [ __ ] to you
right
it could be
don't fight no more
you god can't move you to a cell but
you're gonna go back in here
kick his [ __ ] brains in she told me
no [ __ ] i swear to god she says do it
what you want but don't finish it just
don't destroy him because he wants to be
yeah i went back in as soon as i got
back and i said listen i apologize for
last night
so he put his hand to shake and i
whacked him a [ __ ] shot
and i said [ __ ] this i beat his [ __ ]
brains in
the next day he went to the
warden beds where he grabbed the wood
and he said i want to be moved this
guy's every [ __ ] night
the one looked at me
you fighting with him
i brought a guy's piece of [ __ ] he's a
liar
he's like your [ __ ] face looks like
i'm [ __ ]
like nothing
bleeding knuckles are still bleeding
yeah how'd you get out of this i said
i'd do that to myself bro i do that
because i'm stupid and i'm in jail i do
it for myself the law the warden started
laughing he says all right he says
savvy just slow it down a little bit
so everybody hated this guy everybody
hated him what ended up happening to the
guy did he even make it he you know i
was friendly with a b guys some ab guys
and uh this guy john and he was in the
same unit as being we were in other
units together
and he knew about the fight so this guy
mark was going to leave
they called them marshalls in here
you're going to leave i was so happy he
was leaving
so
john called him he says
mark you leave it yeah
and he put his hand out
mark grabbed his hand he grabbed his
head and hit him a [ __ ] left so you
can't do nothing because the marshals
are waiting
if you don't leave then you're going to
stay there so he wants to get the [ __ ]
out of here anyway so everybody hated
him this guy jimmy the general was a
made guy
he hit him one day with me
you know that's a funny story because he
was he was a biker
and he did tattoos
so he's showing me some of the work he
did because i had a ton of tattoos
and uh he shows me and his wife has her
dress up
so you could see the leg and the work
but she has no panties on right and
she's it's up quite a bit
so i said oh my god
i said this is good work bro
i'm looking right at his wife
so
i said jimmy come here bro
look at this mark does beautiful work
looks like he's got big chalk look at
that
you know be calculated
it's just take a peek at this there's be
[ __ ] over here
so if jimmy comes over looks out he's
laughing
mark says let's pick out that's
beautiful work and italian
yeah
so
we tortured him
i beat him up every night
how long did that last i mean it lasted
about a week and then he just got he
just stopped he just stopped he was he
was literally crying stop it sammy
because as soon as the door clicked and
the guard walked away he knew it was
it was like round three round four let's
go again i just wanted to go are you
guys ever like knocked out on the ground
like after being you know hitting each
other so much was it everything i had
the top bunk
so and i had the bottom bunk
so as soon as the guard was still there
locking he would try and jump on the
chair at the desk and boom shoot up onto
the top bunk and i couldn't get him
you know because if i'm short so when as
i step on the chair to try again he
would kick
and
he tried to keep me the [ __ ] was he was
he an actual monkey
he was like a monkey but he would kick
me to it so i couldn't get on there but
i would i would take the kicks back off
a little bit and then you were trying to
drag him off the top oh i dragged him
off the top a bunch of times but he
would hang on to the thing but it's like
this whole body was in the yeah like
you're doing a hell in a cell match like
you're the undertaker yeah but sammy the
bottom line is you guys shared a cell
together like
how do you even sleep now you just can't
leave yeah exactly
how do you sleep at the end of the night
if we fight for about an hour we could
both go to sleep believe me
you could both go to sleep if you have
to i mean you're so exhausted and so
beat up yeah you know it's just the
whole day now they locked you at night
now you're battling for an hour hour and
a half banging all over the [ __ ]
place
you know you stop it
you just can't keep going in other words
it's not it's not that i want to kill
them i just want to beat them up let me
ask you at the end of the fight do you
say
good night and then like they'll say no
no there's no good nights
that's a great question i mean like they
were telling me [ __ ] and then i would
tell them listen tomorrow because i
wanted them out of the cell i don't want
to fight him every night i said don't
tell the unit manager to move him
i mean you talk about go complain i
don't give a [ __ ] you talk about not
being able to sleep i mean your whole
life man you've lived on the razor's
edge for so long like you do something
you do some work and then you got to
think you know man this is what i just
did could be 25 years if anybody ever
catches me at 25 years of my life any
minute anybody could be a cop anybody
can be undercover any anything that you
speak into can be wired like what you
talk about not being able to go to sleep
like what was it like in the beginning
what was it like you know as you were
moving up the ranks did it ever become
easier did it ever be like well they
haven't caught me yet they're not going
to catch me how did how did you handle
the stress of being in that life i got
caught all my life bro
every [ __ ] thing i ever did just
about especially as a kid i got caught a
lot of times look at my rap sheet i'm
arrested 20 [ __ ] times in my life i'm
arrested one time
on a double homicide that i didn't
commit
i got out on bail hundred thousand
dollar bill back then
i came out i got busted robbing cars and
robbing things to pay [ __ ] lawyers
and things and i got busted a third time
i had three cases going at the same
exact [ __ ] time in my life
when i had those cases so i'm busted a
lot of times
you know i just
this
life of mine i seem to be involved in
everything
i was chosen to go on hits that were
literally impossible
the johnny keys hit
the castellano when i was in three mafia
wars
my life just never stopped i don't know
what happened or why
and
i just kept going when did you enjoy
your life like what was the happiest
phase of your life i always enjoyed my
life my wife my kids
when i went away i had a i bought a farm
when we would go away from the farm
i would get off the highway in jersey it
was cream ridge new jersey bro the mob
everything was out of my head i smelled
those trees
i was in i was in a different
thing when i went home i shut it down
i had two different lives
and i wasn't just
fighting in
[ __ ] all the time it happened i think
maybe my size
it happened
fights more thinking they could get do
something or get away with things
i fought in the ring i don't give a [ __ ]
if i win or lose the fight when i'm in a
fight i want to hurt you
period and i don't give a [ __ ] if you
win
but you're going to know
that i fought you're in a fight yeah
you're going to say bro i beat him up
but
i don't want to fight him again
that's all i do you know but i don't
back up
from anybody in prison but i don't bully
people and i don't i'm good with people
um
you know i i asked patrick i know him a
long time i never beat him up as big as
he is how does it happen
yet and it wouldn't have happened
what are you smiling about it might
happen to you
first of all
off camera gerard was upset because adam
was acting a little too hard around
gerard yeah he felt safe with sam
he had his muscle here with him yeah but
so for the next uh couple hours i'm i'm
looking right at you by tomorrow lose my
number
but sami i guess
let's restate
change the word uh happy
peaceful like if you were to go
think about the most peaceful face of
your life when was it like i'm talking
pure peace and i'm not talking about
when i come home smelling the trees the
kids the family all that stuff i'm
talking pure peaceful
what was that era was it when you were a
kid was it when you were in your team
were you you know a young adult when was
that
no of course when i was a kid i had a
good mother a good father and i had good
friends the neighborhood i played ball i
you know i never did anything
but i was dyslexic and i had trouble in
school
so i think that was my downfall if you
want to call it that i had trouble in
school
you know i told somebody once you see
this paper i told them here read this
paper i'll tell you
read this paper
then i take a blank piece of paper and i
just scribble on it
and i say read that
and you'll tell me i can't read it it's
all scribbling
well that's what this looks like to me
how old were you when you said that when
you showed that well i did that a little
older
but
because people didn't understand it back
then
but school just wasn't for me
you know and kids are cruel in school
when you're they're calling you dummy
they're laughing and this and the other
thing i had a little bit of a temper
especially i like girls they're laughing
they're belittling me in front of a girl
so when after school i'll break your
[ __ ] ass bro so you wouldn't do it no
more
and i think that's what i learned that
you know a good swift punch stops the
laughing and stops the joke and then
whatever if you're joking as a friend
and you're doing something that's one
thing but if you're trying to belittle
me
i don't take that
lightly
and i think that's i got left back in
the fourth grade i got left back in the
seventh grade
and i was in a gang so that was it was
over
that started my life
into a way of crime
now we were in a gang we were like [ __ ]
the mafia i'm not gonna ever be in the
mafia it's us against the world it's all
awesome [ __ ] this is in what middle
school type of things no this is 16 17
18 19
i got drafted into the army during the
vietnam war i came out when i was 21
right back into the ramp is in a gang
at 23 the neighborhood was so saturated
with the mafia you couldn't do anything
so and while i was gone most of my
friends hooked up with somebody
so at 23 i hooked up with the columbo
family and i did my first hit
and the rest was history i have
a start button i don't have a stop
button
whether it was business
whether it was the mafia whether no
matter what it was
and it's until today
there were some young girls who worked
for me i burnt them out too much work
too much drive
um
no no other reason but
i seem to always be like that
i'm just aggressive that way
um
i'm 76
and i'm doing
15 different projects
with you guys
uh mafia states of america
i'm working on a scripted show on a
script
i'm working on a
a possible documentary
um daca series we're talking with people
with i have them on social media i'm
like a social butterfly all over the
[ __ ] place
i don't stop
that's gotta be pretty quiet that's
gonna be pretty wild for you you lived
your whole life trying to keep
everything under wraps and now the
entire world is is snitching on
themselves on a phone all these 16 year
olds are taking like snapchats on
themselves at a party we used to try to
sneak in at night so our parents didn't
know we were partying you lived your
whole life in the shadows and now
everything's on front street i know what
i say a lot of times i say that
what i'm doing i got you know 400 000
now subscribers
i have 50 something million hits on my
podcast and my videos
i said
if john got he was alive and be looking
at this he would be so sick he would say
that's what i wanted to be he wanted the
publicity he wanted he would have loved
this
in my opinion because this is what he
was about everything was a show
the way he dressed acted it wasn't goes
in austria me i was under duck
i don't want to see nothing you know the
agents would say what a pleasure it was
to follow sammy when he was the
underboss
he'd come out of his office
a t-shirt pair of sneakers he'd go in a
schoolyard with some kids playing
handball
it was so different watching him
than watching some other gangsters you
know playing that gangster roll i didn't
do that
low key was for me
now my the roll's reversed
i i'm i'm a [ __ ] social butterfly
youtube youtubers
they call me podfather now
is that just a sign of the time that
things have changed so significantly i
guess i guess it did it's a sign of the
times that i mean i never even saw this
stuff
i mean i went away i was going almost 18
years straight i never even saw these
phones i still have trouble with this
phone
but i mean it's a pleasure really
you get in the car that gives you
directions
do you think do you think uh do you
think technology
uh if technology was around when you
guys were coming up do you think many
guys would have found a different way
different racket to make money and not
doing illegal things do you think it
would be very different or you think
guys would still be doing what they're
doing
because this is helping you make money
this is helping you generate income this
is i mean 400 000 subs you got to very
quickly 50 million pod
you can do sponsorships you can do a lot
of different things that's going on with
you got people that are watching so your
mind is not consumed with
you know hey i need money what do i need
to do to go make money so is this is
this almost
eliminating the thoughts of
i got to figure out a way to make money
and survive do you think that would have
prevented a lot of guys to get into life
with the technology we have today both
from the camera standpoint as well as
way to make money
i don't i don't know i really don't know
but you know my mindset was being a
gangster and i was a gangster the whole
time
i don't think
i would have turned to this now i might
have
had somebody else used to p other people
and took a piece of some business that
they were doing in this field that might
interest me
hollywood might of interest me in the
background
i'm a camera guy i'm in the back i'm i
want to be in the front
now it's different now i am i am in the
front everything's about my voice i
can't even duck i can't even go away
from the weekend but
i don't know
there's two sides of this sword
you can make money with it and people
should use it
and use it properly
and make money but the other side is
that i think the whole country now
is in a weird place
there's people who are doing some of
these platforms who are talking about
being in the mafia they're full of [ __ ]
they're not even they wouldn't have
nothing
and everybody seems a lot of them seem
to be lying so
you got to disciple which one is good
which one is bad which one is so there's
a confusion about all of this so it has
two wedges to this sword
i don't know
and there's a lot of things that are
going on with kids today
that i i mean i don't understand
the whole country is just out of whack
if you would have told me about this
country at this point
if four years ago
three years ago
i would tell you crazy that would never
happen in the united states in what way
which part not every part the
coronavirus the whole thing i mean the
masks no masks i don't even know what to
believe anymore
you used to be you listen to the news
it was gospel oh my god this is what
they're saying on the news cronkite
cronkite although you know when you went
back the cnn the guy who originally
formed cnn said turner people like that
now they disappeared i don't know what's
running it anymore
you can't believe anything anymore
because one day they're telling you one
thing
wear miscs don't wear a mess wear two
masks take a shot take another shot
take a booster take another booster
come on bro what what's going on here
two completely different realities
depending on which channel you watch
yeah yeah and it's do you hear it in all
kinds of [ __ ] you don't know what to
believe
this guy fouchy
i mean
i don't know if he needs a medal the
sexiest man alive guys yeah yeah sexy is
it man to life well he bullshitted the
whole world
he's part of this whole virus like you
don't know if he's a hero or a [ __ ]
he's a [ __ ] he's no [ __ ] hero this
guy
he's no hero he's paid from what i
understand the highest paid
guy in the federal government
he's supposed to be a doctor he's
supposed to care about us
he's funding this thing in china
with money
like we're paying for that
we're paying for
to get a bat
who is disgusting and
has all kinds of viruses and we're
getting those viruses and trying to
transform them into
worse viruses the worst virus and making
it that man could catch it for what
reason are we doing it
the excuses so if man catches this
we could uh cure it that's [ __ ]
because
from the bat you can't even get it
first of all bats don't even live near
us and you can't get it
so you're creating something
to see what you can cure
bro millions of people have died from
this
and the word hero bro this is the
furthest thing from a hero
well i can't explain what i would like
to do to him well with all due respect i
mean listen you you did your crimes and
you did time right but how do you feel
about somebody like fauci
or what just happened where you know we
dropped a predator drone and it took
uh
intense
seven kids it took intense scrutiny from
rand paul for them to admit yeah
actually that wasn't a terrorist that we
killed it was 10 civilians and it was
seven it was an aid worker and seven
children this is our taxpayer dollars
we're we're we just committed a war
crime that was financed by the hours of
our lives every news station said it was
isis k we took him out
everybody was said what a strong move
and the next thing you know the real
reports comes out and it's seven kids
yeah so i gotta ask you is that you know
as somebody that did time and and you
did your crimes and you did time right
but now you look at somebody like fauci
it looks like nothing's gonna happen to
him at all
these guys nothing there's no
accountability whatsoever even small
things the the mayor of uh san francisco
puts the entire city on lockdown and she
puts a mask mandate out and then she's
out there dancing and drinking and
partying with no mask whatsoever i mean
how do you handle something like that
where you were held accountable but but
these people that hold the rest of us
accountable face no accountability in
themselves well let me let me answer
that a little bit
i've never seen the mafia be a predator
against society
we stalled we made money we killed one
another because of rules in our
organization we didn't go out killing
innocent men women children
i mean like people that are outside the
mafia outside of the mafia
and
we didn't do certain things we took a
piece of things that in industries but
we took a piece
these people don't give a [ __ ] about
nobody
they take the whole party
one two
they don't care about men women or
children and innocent people
there's a complete difference
they're nothing like the mafia talk
about the government
the the people who yes the government
and politicians do you think they care
even even some of the media people who
are out there today do they care you go
to college you go to universities you
all your life you're going to be out
there you're going to hold the powerful
hold their feet to the fire are they
doing that no
so
what happened what is happening
and how do you stop it
that's the whole thing so this
technology with patrick and we went into
a whole frenzy about what's going on but
this technology i think it's good
and it has a bad side i don't know if
it's all that good
they're teaching
race theory in prison in schools
i mean i don't know i don't get that
either critical race there crt which is
just watered down marxism feminism well
it's racism because if you're white
and your grandfather owned something or
did something then you're no good
i mean i don't get it my i don't even
know my great grandfather i don't know
what he did or what he didn't do i don't
give two [ __ ] what he did
has nothing to do with me
i know what my mother did i know what my
father did
they were far from being racist
look what they did with jews they they
they loved them were their neighbors
huh or rich grew up middle class
brooklyn just like you know everybody
else you know it's like you you weren't
down in the south running the plantation
you know like you would what do you hold
a held accountable for and i don't think
even those people i don't knock those
people that was the time and that's what
they did
and racism didn't start
with bringing blacks into white people
didn't bring blacks into this country
and use them as slaves like it's the
histories where did they come from
started in africa
the strong african tribes grabbed
strong
men and women and sold them in africa
shippers who went there said
wow this is we can make a lot of money
a guy looks like a strong guy we could
sell him he could be a worker somewhere
that's how it started
it started with black people doing it
against black people
and then it went all around the world
with shippers and whatever
this isn't a thing that some kid is born
today
whether they're latin
whether they're white whatever they are
they're not guilty of anything and you
can still feel bad for who it happened
to without saying you know any other of
course
of course you could and and when you're
wiping out history that's why they want
to wipe out history because this is what
it really was
so of course you can feel bad
i would hate that i would hate to see
that i have a ton of black friends i
just was on gangster chronicles i was
treated like a king with them the same
type of environment all black guys
joke and laugh and we had a great time
of course i feel bad what they did then
but that's why you want history you want
to change it
vietnam
we went there they were telling me when
i was a kid training
they're going to come here they're going
to rape your mom your sisters they're
going to kill us they're going to do
this they're saying that the viet cong
was going to come here and do that that
was the
propaganda that you were being served
that's what i was training on the
but that's [ __ ] i don't know of one
vietnamese guy or a woman who's bad the
only vietnamese woman i know they do
your nails they do your toenails your
fingernails they're polite they're good
people when we left that country
that country never did anything it got
better
so it was all [ __ ]
so what we're doing now we're [ __ ]
with countries all over the place for
what
iran korea this one that one
all these countries afghanistan
where the [ __ ] are we where are we going
with this technology and everything
we're doing this technology we just
killed
innocent people the guy was had water
drums because he's a humanitarian for
people who didn't have water
and seven kids 10 people legitimate
people we killed
so now
and we'll just put that on the back
burner that don't mean nothing how do
you think those people are gonna feel
they're gonna love us
they're families they got lost
families they're gonna hate us
and and we're doing these things now
i go with the me too movement you pat a
girl on the ass
you're in trouble
me too will go crazy on you
where the [ __ ] is the metoo movement
about these girls and women
that are about to be slaughtered in
afghanistan what does the metoo movement
stop at the border
what about all those people
what are these people in the border here
i don't know what's going on in this
country i'll tell you the truth dude i
look at this border
we opened up the border
it's a million
and a half plus people
got in
already gotta wear a mask
take shots do this do that they don't
have to wear a mask they don't have to
take shots
they don't have to be tested they can
put on buses they're shipped all over
the country
i feel sorry for them when i see them
coming through the water old ladies
little kids and this and that
but i feel kind of sorry for the whole
country for us
when do we care about us well sammy you
let's use your knowledge of history
maybe to our advantage for us that
weren't around when you were a kid if i
ain't that [ __ ] no
you said you
yeah about history
i'm not going to ask you about julius
caesar here
i don't want to know about marcus
aurelius here i want to all right guys
when you were a kid uh
in in
the 60s is that fair to say all right
all right i mean things couldn't have
been any worse jfk assassination mlk
assassination
bobby kennedy uh sirhan sirhan just got
out of jail after 50 freaking years
you were a kid growing up race relations
you know
race riots race riots
uh civil rights movement everything was
going on
is it fair to say that we're
we're doing better now than than then i
mean it's crazier things are now let me
give you a little example of that yes we
had a thing with the italian people the
italian american civil rights league
we had big rallies
a hundred thousand people
not one window was broken not one person
in the streets was beaten up not one cop
was assaulted
a hundred thousand
there was irish jewish italian people
there was every nation but joe colombo
did get shot but that's by a guy
who yeah a radical nut
shot
but i'm saying the people a hundred
thousand of them
there was nothing
so we have somebody gets shot a black a
black guy they put his knee on his neck
which is horrible as soon as i saw that
i said that's a disgrace
this guy is the the cop his life is over
for what he did and what i watched yeah
the other three cops are schmucks
just watching him just watching him
you're a cop take out your gun to your
fellow cop and tell him get your [ __ ]
knee off his neck or i'll [ __ ] shoot
you get it off
that's what you should've did
you didn't
so you're just as much to blame not as
much but you should be quiet and thrown
out you're not a cop
you're not a good cop anyway but to
gerard's point
it seems like back then
public figures were being assassinated
like you said the colombo jfk mlk now
it's just
everyday citizens getting shot
and it's everyday citizens getting knee
on their neck it's actually why is that
so different like you don't public fears
aren't getting assassinated germany just
actually doesn't have to do with america
but it's to your point germany actually
just disbanded their highest level of
government police what we would consider
like state police because they said that
they had an unfriendly opinion of the
elites
that was the actual excuse that they
gave to disband it they had an
unfriendly opinion of the elites so the
elites just got rid of them so yeah it
it's upside down it used to be the
civilians holding the elites accountable
now it's the elites holding the
civilians at bay it's a very strange
time certainly have shifted yeah it's
almost back to being futile listen all
those people you said kennedy got shot
yeah
i saw the whole country crying right
when he got shot
i don't see no revolution i didn't see
wars i didn't see riots i didn't see
anything
republicans are crying the same thing
with martin luther king i seen people
white people all kinds of people crying
this was a shame he was a good man
i didn't see riots i didn't see nothing
all of a sudden
now everything is a riot well let's not
forget these people are paid to riot
yeah well they're paid in some people
who's
paying them how come we never figured
that out no we know who they are
there's a guy who's from another country
george soros
we know who this guy is see that's the
difference with a mafia dude
now
if the mafia had something to do with
this that guy would be dead
soros yeah without doubt mafia would
whack him in [ __ ] two seconds
he ain't doing this to us in our country
we had neighborhoods we lived in we
protected people those jews living on
the side of us you couldn't [ __ ] with
them with me sitting in the middle or my
father or the whole neighborhood
it didn't it didn't happen we had black
people in in living in our neighborhood
small little church good people you
couldn't [ __ ] with them
we wouldn't allow it you couldn't come
into a neighborhood and rape our
women yeah or or kill a kid or be a
pedophile we would kill you too you took
care of your neighborhoods we took out
we did we did business we took care of
our neighborhood they were our people we
loved them all yeah it was a whole thing
with my father except for people
rapist or child molester or something
like that women love them yeah and these
these things so he could if he paid to
come and create a ride in our
neighborhood but he better stay out of
the country
so i don't even know how a guy gets away
with it or fouchy all these people doing
these things how are they getting away
with it
you couldn't get away with it years ago
or in certain mafia areas
but yet these so-called legitimate
people uh are better than the mafia
and and this is happening i i don't get
it did you see what happened in ducktown
philadelphia it's it's impossible to
find a video but to your point they were
rioting in uh in philadelphia and then
they got down to duck town and there was
a whole bunch of people out there with
bats and then out there in their in
their uh in their guinea teas their wife
beaters and it was white guys black guys
and they were all you know going uh
black lives matter was going nuts and
they just stood there and they were like
you guys aren't coming down this block
they were like what do you mean when i
come down this block and they're like
you're not coming down this block
this is not the riot goes that way it
doesn't come this way and they stopped
them and there was like three black
dudes that were standing with them and
they were like you guys are gonna you
know basically they would it was very
very vulgar but they were like you guys
are gonna take his side they were like
yeah absolutely you cross this line
you're in our territory we're gonna bust
you up and that was it now that was on
the news for about 30 seconds and it was
never played again because that was the
blueprint for the rest of the country of
how they should handle this
how they should handle this they realize
that they they put it out there on the
news because it was salacious and
everybody they were going to get a lot
of views and then they took it off the
news and it's almost impossible to find
online because that is the blueprint for
how you do it just fighting back not
taking it hey here's the deal exactly
there's the line in the sand
chase momentary brought up the same
situation what's next is your decision
right
listen i came out of prison i went and i
lived in a regular neighborhood in
arizona
they probably said oh [ __ ] here goes the
neighborhood
everybody blows their horn
waves to me sees me neighbor comes in i
saw you sammy you won i made stew would
you like him i mean i get along with
everybody
they they know that i'm i might be
dangerous i might whatever
but i am but i'm not now but
they all accepted me like
it was perfect neighborly yeah they knew
actually they came to me once or twice
they rented a house
some guys and
rented the house
and they were loud with music and this
and that so i said what do you want me
to do
well could you talk to them
i said
i'll think about it
and i did go and talk with them
and i said bro
the people that i talk with them they're
going to call the cops so you got a
choice
calm it down
and why are you talking to me
i'm trying to do you a favor
be quiet
certain hours these people got to sleep
they got to live they got kids
calm it down
you guys want your mind your business
this is these kids are telling you this
one kid college kids whatever one kid
yeah well i don't know if it's college
they look like [ __ ] idiots to me but
one kid
wanna mind that business
i said listen bro
i'm gonna tell you
i'm i'm talking to you nice telling you
you can get in trouble with the cops
i might tell you something else bro
i don't even like the way you talk maybe
[ __ ] the cops
maybe i'll take this as a problem my
problem and your problem
we could do that
another guy tells him
oh hey bro i think that sent me the bull
he
got all fuzzed up with that [ __ ]
backed up and he stopped
they stopped
the neighbors love me they think i'm
[ __ ] god to them
but i didn't do it in an intimidating
way i didn't like to tell them
i don't know what to tell them i don't
want to threaten them until they start
giving me stupid answers well how do you
how do you handle the internet comments
then man you're such a guy with respect
you're so old school with respect i mean
the comment section must be i don't even
bother i have
you know i we go off have these tech
guys around us i got a 99 point
something rate of positive things so
you're going to get these little creeps
sitting in the basement and texting
you know this guy's a creep and this
guy's no good i'm sure patrick has some
[ __ ]
he's a good man he probably don't have
it but everybody has somebody who wants
to be a little creep in the basement
they get off on it i don't even bother
with it
i don't answer it i don't bother me
i don't care now if i had a man you know
a million people
maybe that would bother me but it
doesn't bother me listen i had a bad
history
i accept what i did
and i accept
you know certain comments about it
um i'm not going to make father of the
year i'm not going to make i'm not going
to become the president of the united
states but i'm a human being like
everybody else i did my time i did
whatever i stand up to what i did
um i did a lot of good things bad things
and ugly things so i i
i take that i don't i don't let it
bother me
let's just avoid it sammy uh let's
transition into
uh you were talking about a couple guys
on the internet i asked this from
michael i'm just curious to know what if
you can have any comments on it or not
uh
names that are coming up
uh recently jimmy calandra's coming up
uh i think you and him did something
together
a light's coming up johnny russo we've
had him on as well
uh
who what do you think about some of
these guys and what they're doing on
social i ask michael the same question
i did i know jimmy calandra he's a
friend of mine and i did have him in my
place he came down he was going to get a
hotel room i said listen bro i'm living
alone you want to just come and live
with me i just got my dog with me yeah
yeah so we lived together for about four
or five days
and uh he came on my show i did a show
with him we had some laughs like we're
doing now i'm talking
and then one or two people i don't want
to name names but one or two people
exploded
because he was arguing with one of those
names or a couple of those names you're
talking about
and they were saying that i encouraged
him to do that which i did i didn't
encourage him i i encouraged him when i
talked to them i said there's a lot of
[ __ ] out there
put it on the side don't get into it
they want to do this
they want you
so they can get hits and they could get
subscribers and they could get views so
they try to get into an argument with
you once you're going back and forth
you're feeding right into what they want
just put them on the burn but jimmy has
a little bit of a temper and he didn't
he exchanged back and forth with them a
couple of times
and uh
and they blamed me for that
which it doesn't matter to me i don't
care
and uh
so i don't bother with some of those
names you just mentioned i don't even
bother with them i did bother with one
because one of them does they like it
when i came home and i got out of prison
he threw me a couple of dollars right
away first guy
so
i try to
reciprocate by saying he's a good guy
he's a tough guy he's this he's that
should try to help him with his show and
all that [ __ ]
then he wanted me to come on and do
certain things and i didn't want to be
bothered with that
i'm i'm not i'm not i'm a truthful
person if i do something
listen i take credit for that or
make maybe that's not the word credit
but i take my my responsibilities for
what i did
i mean i got people that'll call me i
got people's kids
without murders i'm involved and i spoke
to them
people's families i spoke to them
this is what happened
this is what it was this is what the
truth is because a lot of them stuff
they hear is their lies
in other words i'm involved in three
mafia awards 19 murders i didn't go out
and i never got up one morning and said
listen i'm gonna go kill somebody
that was part of the mafia so were they
one woman at my sentence i won't say the
names
she told my judge
when i was first getting sentenced
give him life
it's a killer is this he's that he's a
serial killer he's this and that
so the judge looked at her and read her
statement
and the judge says
your brother
who you're talking for was in his crew
did it ever bother you
he was killing people with him
it only bothered you when he got killed
it never bonded you before
killing other people
he just shut her [ __ ] right the [ __ ]
down with that statement really
and it was truthful
and they just disregarded what she was
saying
because it was all [ __ ] so that's
what you deal with you deal with all
this hypothetical [ __ ]
you know you're protecting him he was a
saint anybody who died there was saint
you know after they died but before they
died they were involved in five murders
or whatever
how did he become the same after he died
so
so in your mind is
anybody that was in that life they were
fair game it's they got what they signed
up for anybody you know the real problem
is if somebody had done something like
demayo did things to people outside of
life that that's that's crossing the
line
two things i'll get to the mail in a
minute but the thing is
this is gonna sound strange but
i'm a samurai warrior
in japan they're samurais
they fight they're very dangerous they
cut off arms heads legs when they lose
battles they take a [ __ ] thing and
stab it and they there was a culture in
japan
they're samurais they're warriors
they're loved over there and respected
but they don't do this outside of their
thing
so when i'm talking to somebody now the
guy called me assembler warrior
he said you have the mafia is a culture
within this country
that did a lot of
good things a lot of [ __ ] up things
so
but we did it within our culture
so we're warriors maybe not i'm not a
japanese and i'm not a samurai but
similar
if you want to break it down and every
country has that
culture
so we're different uh which will lead me
right into roy demaio
roy dometo became a serial killer
i mean
i'm about to do a video about him and
his crew
one time i went to him and
paul was going to make guys
and i knew him and i said
they're going to open the books again
and they're going to make guys you've
got some good guys around you you're
going to put anybody up for it
he said sam
my coffee boy killed five people with me
what
your coffee boy killed five people yeah
he says i got 200 hits
200.
i said what the [ __ ] is giving you this
kind of work
he says nobody
i get a lot of work from the boss and
this and that
from nino
but
we have the bar on the corner
he said
my uncle works there they used to call
him dracula
he says he calls me up at 4 30 3 30
we're playing cards tells me there's a
guy left one guy drunk
we come in we snatch them we bring them
in we kill them cut them up get rid of
them
the guy did nothing
no
i keep my cruise [ __ ] tight
sharp you know what i mean
i didn't want to answer that i said yeah
yeah i do the same thing yeah
but in my head i was saying this is a
sick
[ __ ] guy he crossed that line he's a
[ __ ] cereal because killing [ __ ]
innocent people
and this is why the mafia killed him
we we're not serial killers
if we become a rapist
a child molester
or a serial killer we will kill you
within our ranks we will kill you we're
not proud of you we don't like you
we will kill you
we killed for different reasons you
broke rules or you did certain things
but those things you got killed for sure
we don't give a [ __ ] who you are
so
if there's there's a difference in our
life it's hard to understand i think for
other people legitimate people don't
understand it and this is why i'm trying
to do
in my scripted show i
i'm doing a scene that i go after
another
hiccup
an older very very experienced hickory
i'm young
i'm a guy already
but not a pimple on his ass
they picked me to go after them
because
they feel that this guy who's very very
smart very sharp very cunning
will underestimate me
he will underestimate my
looks i look young
i'm supposed to be he's told or jerk off
a guy who brings messages
and sammy i think can pull this off
and this is the head on johnny keys
and i
i did
i snatched him
when i had him in the truck in a van
he looked at me and said
a punk
a jerk-off
a messenger
with five families in new york
and the philadelphia
family couldn't do
you did
you have me sitting in this van
it was the most amazing [ __ ] thing i
ever heard
now
when we do this
i don't want to do it in my movie where
i just shoot him
or vice versa
the people
i want to make it known
what went through his
head and what went through my head
they're going to see
what made both of us tick
not just shoot them up gang them and
doing this and doing that
it's going to be different
he talked to me in the van
they said
you're good
you're really good
you're [ __ ] up a little bit
okay
what i do
he said look at the windows
truckers
they have these cds they'll look in this
window
they'll see me
tied up
they'll see you they'll see these other
guys they'll call the cops
i was thinking he's critiquing him
i'm i'm looking at him and i'm saying to
my i say a word
but i'm saying to myself
he's telling me
how to do a hit
on himself
he don't want cops involved
the [ __ ] kind of guy do i got here
then he tells me
we're talking like we are
saying
go in my pocket i got pills in here
what kind of pills
nitroglycerin pulp
i have pains in my chest and i want to
die of a heart attack
i go in his pocket
as i take them and out he says put one
under my tongue
if i don't get better put one another
one every five minutes
i put one in his mouth
now i'm saying to myself
you don't want to die of a heart attack
he's about to die he knows it
you don't want to dive on thing
we
talk i get to know him
i fall in love with him
i love him more than any [ __ ] man on
the planet
he's
he
he's what my fear is about he's what
goes in austria is about
he showed me how to die
like a man
later on he says
sammy i want two favors more
what
the guy who pulls the trigger
if it's not you
let it be a friend of ours meaning a
maid guy
you got it
and take my shoes off
why do you want me to take your shoes
off
he says i told my wife she knew i was in
this life
she knew there was a war that broke out
in philadelphia
i told my wife i'll die with my shoes
off don't worry about it
meaning he'll be home with his shoes off
he's not gonna die in the street
i said that's pretty heavy stuff bro
he said
she'll know
i was thinking about her
in my final minutes
of life
i didn't want to kill this guy
it broke my [ __ ] heart
what kind of guy is this
but i had i was under orders
i did kill him
nikki skye for won the war for what i
did
the next day i drove to paul's house
it was done it was in the papers that a
heavyweight mobster by the name of
johnny keys
was found in staten island in the dumps
that
were no shoes on
when i went to paul's house the maid let
me in
paul got up and came running
over grabbed me
you did it
i didn't answer
he said what's the matter
i said what i did last night
i killed
what my fear is about what goes in
austria is about
what we're about
he should have been the boss not
i'm not happy about it
i feel dirty
he said
anybody else will be jumping up and down
they're going to know our family
took care of it
every boss every under boss and every
council he has
going to know
that you did it
nikki's gonna know he won the war and
you did it
and you're disturbed
yeah
i don't give a [ __ ] what they think
he said to me sammy don't change
stay like that
grammy hugged me kiss me let me go i
don't want to talk about this no moms
because it [ __ ] wrecks me thinking
about him
and he taught me how to die i always
wondered
if my time comes from ever in a van
my last minute
whether it's a hit guy whether it's
cancer whatever the [ __ ] it is could i
die like this guy
could i be him
i hope so you know you never begged it
to change your mind never tried to talk
you out of it he tried to do one thing
once
at the end he said sami i have a lot of
money i can make you a very wealthy man
i said please john
don't do that
and i've developed a tremendous [ __ ]
respect for you
you told me this is good enough so i'm
telling you it is good so much there's
no money in the [ __ ] world like it's
trying to stop me
and don't do it don't even say
they it's
you are ghosts an austrian true and
through
racketeers
don't do that
dogs mafiosos
gangsters they do that he was a gangster
there's a difference
going back to the original question
there's a difference in the stories
about making money and about that
there's no money in the [ __ ] world
and
the respect i have
then
the love i'm not ashamed to say i love
another man i don't not in that way but
in the respect i have
and i
i talk about it on my podcast
and uh it's actually
it sounds like a commercial so i'm not
even going to say it what part of it
it's it's on my podcast
and
it's an incredible thing
and to me it was
a lesson that goes in austria that i
that i learned
that is the most amazing thing in the
[ __ ] world
and i about life
about life
how this man thought about his wife who
the [ __ ] at 70 years old
gives a [ __ ] about their wife how she
thinks when she drops dead
don't even exist
this guy did that
so
i don't know
what a way to answer the question by the
way it took you 45 minutes to answer the
quote not even 45 minutes an hour to
answer the question and you answered it
that way the difference between a
racketeer and a
gangster i i i would have never thought
the way you do you you know that that
made it very clear between the two you
know
sammy uh not to transition out you know
on this story
for me i see you and i see you telling
the stories you're a true believer in
the world you chose to live i don't
think to you was about the lifestyle i
think to you was more about
the code of that life
um
the the one question when i when i
listen to you
you're very charming you're very
charismatic you're extremely believable
and you're in your own way you're
inspirational which is
very interesting do you ever think about
that maybe
uh the the
the other side of this question is do
you ever think about maybe
you're inspiring people to want to be
like you do you think you're inspiring
younger guys to want to become gangsters
or what part of your message is to say
do not choose to live my life
because you don't even know yourself
that last 20 minutes
if a 20 year old kid listens to that
that message may be like well i want to
be that guy because i want to be i want
people to be proud of me to get if a guy
like that got you know sammy to get
emotional on a podcast where he said i
don't want to talk about it anymore i
want to get that kind of respect in my
life can you please unpack that so young
person listening to this is not going to
get stuck on the fact that i want to be
that person one day i said it 100 times
you want to be me
god
i got 22 years in prisons
i killed people friends
i've seen death over and over again
there's no win from being a gangster
freedom is the most important thing you
can be
don't take me as a [ __ ] i'll take him
look at patrick when he's doing
a lot of things
a lot of money wealthy good life
just had a baby
i lost all that
this isn't something to recruit
this is something to understand what
you'll be
you'll kill your [ __ ] best friend on
orders
and you'll do it or you'll die
you may not live to [ __ ] 40.
and if you do probably a good hunk of
that will be in prisons
they'll tell you when to [ __ ] when to
eat when to go to sleep when to get up
if that's what you want
but there's life out here
like i'm doing now you want to be me
i'm making money
doing
legitimate things
and it's not just because it's my
story it's i could do it anybody's
thought
um
there's there's a bunch of different
ways in life
you don't have to go to college
there's money being a [ __ ] carpet a
plumber electrician
in trades you know [ __ ] college
they make a lot of money
[ __ ] up your boat they tell you
your sink
call a plumber see what happens
guy comes in for 15 20 minutes a half
hour and you went for [ __ ] 200.
trade schools trade schools become
become something else because learn how
to edit out of this there's an industry
out here
doing this
there's people sitting around us all
over the place
they make a living they don't go to
prison they go home their wife their
kids their mothers their fathers do it
this is not to recruit
this is to make you
understand johnny keys in that you could
have been johnny keys
i could have been johnny keys
there's no recruiting i mean if you want
to be if i can't stop people from being
crooks or gangsters or anything else but
my life is a perfect life look at it
i don't know why i'm here yes god
sometimes i believe in god too i asked
god
i was shot twice stabbed once
is there a special is there a thing you
need or want from me
that you want me to do
how did i survive these [ __ ] things
wasn't easy
wasn't easy on my wife or my kids so if
you think this is a good role for you
[ __ ] you go do it but i'm telling you
you're not going to wind up in a good
way
so
but i'm not going to you know i don't go
telling kids what to do and what not to
do do whatever you want to do
still believe in god after everything
you've seen and you've been through how
do you still have that faith
you know
his faith is
i always believed in god when i went to
prison i
joined an indian group
indian native american
native american i joined the group
because they shut down smoking
in
2004 i believe it was and i wanted to
smoke and there was no smoking no more
in the prisons and federal prisons you
were done it was over
so i saw them smoking in a circle
passing the pizza pipe around
wow i went to them and i said listen
i'd like to join because they had
probably religious exclusions or
something
so
they said you got to go to the chaplain
in feds they could change your religion
so i said okay i went to the chat class
i want to become a native american
they did it
they changed my religion and i went and
i in that circle they accepted me
and i smoked and i stole some of that
tobacco to bring it back into myself
so when i at night i put on the tv nice
cup of coffee i light up a cigarette
after the god makes his rounds and i
smoke my [ __ ] brains out
but i got to respect their religion
what is their religion their religion is
they believe in grandfather the
grandfather
is a road to god they believe in god
like anybody else
a higher power yeah well everybody
believes in god the muslims believe in
god allah they go to god
the christians believe in it jews
believe in it everybody believes that
everybody has a separate road to god
i'm no different i'm just not on some of
your roads you tell me well if you
didn't find jesus you ain't going to
heaven
well maybe i won't
maybe i won't i don't know
but i believe in god just like everybody
else so this grandfather they talk about
this religion yeah
grandfather you know that's that's their
religion so i did it for five years with
that i even went into wicca
some guys friends of mine said sammy
you're not an indian no
that's the choice that's the witches
well it's which is it's not which is
like you see on television which is
is in their religion a witch is nothing
more than a term like a priest
a rabbi or but he's a witch
he can't perform anything
as a witch he can't do anything
about black magic it's all that that's
television [ __ ]
but the wicked
they do have some weird but thing but
there's still a religion that wants to
go wherever all religions got some weird
[ __ ]
you know but that's that's an
organization
and their road and their money
but god is god everybody believes in god
some to different degrees and weird
degrees and whatever but of course i
believe in god
you know i do i learned how to do
artwork in prison
sometimes in arizona where um
pretty legit work though like this is
not like artwork like artwork like real
work
yeah i've seen some of the work he's
done it's it's very impressive like
painting like skulking oh no no
seriously like i don't know i do chuck
hole
do you have any afterwards can you show
them some of the pictures yeah i got
them on my phone my girl can show it to
you yeah but
in arizona i get up and i look at the
sunset or the sunbrides or something and
i look at it
and it's it's so
[ __ ] beautiful
and i say
who could do that
god
who could do that beauty
who could do the beauty around you
who could
have babies coming out of
a woman's body
god has got to be in
there somewhere in everybody's mind
the worst of the worst i think unless
it's completely insane i'm not insane
so i believe in god
and i believe that
whatever i did when it comes time
and i talk to him if i could get up
there somewhere
and we're going to have an argument
about
everything i did
that's what people will tell
me and i'm going to talk to him
about everything he did
there's so many kids that die
in so many ugly [ __ ] ways bro
you could have stopped me anytime you
wanted you could stop that anytime you
wanted
it's got to be a purpose there's got to
be reasons
why things happen
i don't one thing i'm not is a fake or a
phony or a liar
i did a lot of horrible things but i'm
none of those things
and i think god will look at me and say
you were none of those
i make lambs
and i make
lions
you're a [ __ ] lion
maybe that's the answer i don't know i
really don't know
it's not to really discuss now or tell
other people that their religion is
wrong or my religion is right or yours
is wrong or just you you this you muslim
he's alright
god will determine it at some time or
we'll go back to wicca
where all energy
our body is energy
when we die
our body energy goes and floats all over
to animals to trees to bushes that have
some another human
to other things
so
that's an interesting thought too so i
don't knock anybody's religion or
anybody's anything they have their own
opinions their own choice
that's what we need and we need to
respect everybody else's choices
i think that's the next sit down i'd
watch that to sit down
sammy and god across the table have to
sit down that's the thing we got 26
minutes left and i got a couple things i
do want to get into one of the things i
want to get into is if you can pull up
rudy's clip when rudy talks about
michael uh
gotti and sammy
when i asked a question about uh are
some people
uh um is this the one
kai
yeah
and are some people inherently bad and
what he says about that so if you can
play this
do you think if a sammy if a michael if
a frank
if a
leonetti
had your
parenting and your upbringing meaning
your parents your mom and dad
do you think they would have gone
straight or do you think it's in them to
say no i'm still gonna go do the
shortcut what do you think it's a little
hard to say about the people you don't
know so let me tell you about michael
because i know michael the best there's
no doubt that if michael had the right
direction and the right parenting he'd
have been a very successful
legitimate
something important
a decent guy
respected his father which is a good
thing except it was the wrong father to
respect right
and i'm gonna guess on the others just
what i know of i think
there are a few people that are
genetically inherently bad evil
even but most people are shaped that way
by circumstances i i think
i could have gone the other way if my
parents
kept me in brooklyn and
i mean i hope i wouldn't have i hope
something else would have stopped me but
there's a chance i could have gone in
the other direction so when i prosecuted
people
it was always a
sense of empathy for them
so they were quite human i mean they
were human people some of them were
gotti was a guy who liked killing
there's something sinister
and sadistic about john you believe that
i know that how about sammy
don't know
okay
don't know don't know
what do you think about what do you have
to say
i i don't know i think he looked gay
when he was moved
he was [ __ ] married i don't know what
the [ __ ] you're not a fan of rudy i'm
not a fan of rudy no okay i'm not a fan
of rudy
listen i'm not i am not against cops and
prosecutors
i i'm against
when
you think
what you did is harmless
you're an italian
he's an italian i was so right
what you did to your own kind
on many occasions you have no flaws
your mom and dad was perfect
depending on their upbringing that's an
insult to me
my
my outbreaking was impeccable
from my family
i'm the total opposite of what they were
and i don't think so i think i got a
good side
and i think i got the good side from
them
but
when you sit down and you make judgments
like that i don't know
of course you don't know me from a
[ __ ] hole in the world so he can't
really make a proper decision
he actually says nice things about
michael michael must have paid him off
to say these [ __ ] things but he said
some nice things about michael
but i don't like it tears out money yeah
yeah yeah rocket is our buddy so he's
looking at a record so anyway
what i was going to say is that
the part of saying he looked up to his
father that's a good thing
but not that father so he's knocking his
father
so i don't think that's a good thing to
even say if you liked him and he did a
good thing and he said a good thing i
think sonny was a good thing
a good father
in a good way
in a different way he was a gangster he
was the ultimate type of gangster
he didn't instill anything
negative in a way
i think he instilled that he loved them
in his way
i don't think i instilled anything
negative to my son and my daughter i
probably did in our way
maybe your mother and father maybe your
mother and father or your mother and
father
and and
put something in your mind in a way
and we're going to blame them because
you're not 100
like he wants you to be
i don't i don't buy that
now there's a lot of things your mother
and father teach you
that
are wrong
but they mean well
there's a difference he don't understand
that
there's a
they'll tell a girl what to do
maybe they're wrong
maybe it won't work
for them
but they meant well
now the times change
so it may not work out well for the girl
or the guy or whatever
when you get into families and you talk
about families and things like that
each person is an individual
nobody does exactly like their mother
and father teaches them
nobody does
there's your environment the
neighborhood your friends your relatives
other people your marriage there's so
many [ __ ] things that form your life
and how you think
things you see
i saw the movie jaws
i saw that [ __ ] shark eating people
bro
i i'm like a little dick i don't i don't
go past my knees in the [ __ ] water
by the way
this guy must have your jeans
without swimming in the ocean
shark can't get me on land bro taking
you out of the ocean
i'll go swim out there i'm swimming laps
he's like up to his ankles i'm not going
anywhere good bro put me on land with a
gorilla i'll take my chances out there
i'm on the plate
what do you think about what he said
about gotti like he said gotti i know he
didn't say like he said i know god is a
killer
i think god he had a temper
i um
um
i think
john was more of a narcissist
i think a lot of people say well i don't
think he ever shot well i put your head
in front of him
when he's holding the gun see what he'll
do i think he'll blow your [ __ ] head
off in two seconds flat if he wanted to
so to say he didn't pull the trigger can
he give an order
he can kill
for sure
i think he got
he had a temper and a half
i think there was a couple of situations
where
his neighbor there was an accident and
they killed a neighbor and the neighbor
disappeared and all that [ __ ] but i
think he was goaded into that
by his wife drove him [ __ ] nuts plus
he was sick about losing his child
he made a mistake
in my opinion
so when you do those kinds of things
when you kill outside the life for
reasons like that
you're going to be looked at in a whole
different light
like we talked about before
you're killing somebody an innocent
person
myself was hit by a car
my neighbor
he's still i think he's still alive but
if he's dead he's 100 years old so
that's the only reason he's dead in
other words i didn't kill him
i wouldn't do that but that's an
accident
so i don't know i don't want to label
john as
he loved
to kill
i don't think he loved to kill any more
than i didn't love to kill
he did what he had to do for the life i
loved him
i was attached at the hip with him
he turned on me backstab i turned on him
we played chess
i checkmated
simple as that i have no hard feelings
towards them if we were alive together
now and i know what i know now i would
shoot him in the [ __ ] head in two
seconds flat boom right now right here
from the whole [ __ ] world straight up
you betrayed me i did everything for you
i got you out of every case i'm behind
and the government knows it every case
he beat i'm [ __ ] behind it
bribing people threatening people doing
all kinds of [ __ ]
making things disappear
killing people for you
wearing those nostrils together we're
brothers
it's your tape
it's you on tape
not me
and you want to sacrifice me
you want to help the government put me
away
so i i turned on him
if you turn on me i will turn on you
i don't turn on people i don't backstab
i don't [ __ ] people but if you turn on
me or you [ __ ] with me i'm gonna [ __ ]
with you or i'm gonna turn on you
i don't take it lightly and i'm i'm
aggressive
in that fashion right away
and that's what happened but i do love
him i feel bad how he died die like a
[ __ ] animal in prison and this guy
talking about he looked like a [ __ ] you
know [ __ ] you know you [ __ ]
[ __ ] what do you know
what do you know how many people did you
[ __ ] put away did you bury did you do
you have any [ __ ]
shame or any [ __ ] grief sometimes i
felt bad they're humans no you didn't
feel [ __ ] bad you [ __ ] dick
you didn't feel bad
sammy some people may some people may
say
you know they call them the american
mayor okay
and the streets of new york if you you
know ask regular guys that are not in
the life and you ask about rudy
they'll say he cleaned the streets of
new york i felt safer because of
giuliani
i felt safer because of what rudy did
yeah law and order gave me a certain
level of peace
i was living in that community i was
scared for my life i was scared of what
was going to happen and you hear these
stories you hear these stories being
told i felt that way okay i liked what
he did
okay as a mate
got it so him cleaning the streets on
what he did yeah
you can boast about that all the [ __ ]
you want
you can even boast about being a cop
i don't know plenty of cops and agents
they have a job to look for me a bad guy
and put me the [ __ ] away i'm not mad at
them
don't do that don't say that what the
[ __ ] do you know about john gotti
oh here's my opinion shut your [ __ ]
mouth in that area
boast about what you did
boast about what you did on 9 11.
boast about cleaning up the city
i'm with you you did that i agree
you were great
you were one of the better mayors
i'll have a whole conversation about him
mrs great mayor
i don't like his statements
i don't like his statements about
parents
our parents
i'm not talking about your parents i
don't like you
i'm not talking about what your parents
taught you i don't give a [ __ ] about
your parents
but and i understand how people feel
about them
now
they could those same people
could understand how i feel about it and
if they don't then [ __ ] dislike me
or do what you want
there's a two-way street with everything
and everybody
i talked to you the other night you're a
classy [ __ ] guy what you do
is in your life the people you have
around you
it's a class [ __ ] act
now i gotta try to think of something i
don't like about you so
i can say something but
i'll find something sooner or later but
you'll find it right now i don't have it
we're all looking sammy all of us
sammy
when we talked when we sat down we also
talked about the chin we talked about
the chin multiple times yeah and you
know did you see the did you see when
michael was here on the podcast
yeah yeah would you so you saw one the
video about chen or no did you see it i
think i did okay so you heard what rudy
said about chennai he was never a number
he thought he was number two but he was
really number six how long does that
clip by the way is it a shorter
collection is this the one where michael
took a walk with uh
with uh no no this is uh no not this one
i want you to oh yeah that's it yeah so
go from the part what he says do you
have the beginning part what they say
about the chin yeah did we play that
last time or no
uh no we started okay so why don't you
go and play what michael and sammy said
about the chin and then go to what rudy
says about the chin
said
what he wanted to say he had the walls
he was a rusher he had the brains to
save this is people that goes in austria
he told another boss john was the boss
told another boss
that we were going to do a big raid
and we were going to arrest the number
one or number two people in each family
they did that about two weeks before
well chen giganti
who thought he was number two in the
japanese family but he wasn't
because everybody hated him
they told him he was number two it was
like number eight
chin is the guy who walked around in the
robes and acted like he was crazy well
he was crazy
he was a
borderline personality disorder in the
military he was actually i think
officially
officially uh diagnosed as a paramedic
schizophrenic he was yeah somebody but
he played that he played it up
so
this information comes out
one of the issues comes in until the
unit you couldn't believe this
chin checked himself in a loss
he thinks we're going to arrest him
can be very disappointed when we don't
arrest them
did you end up with the word eventually
but not for that i got it we're not for
that so it it it displayed to the whole
world they've been they've been lying to
him for several years tell you send your
number two you're number two now i
wanted to yes again since praiseworthy
don't listen to it
wow fat tony knew he was nuts so he made
him think he was number two but he never
he said how come i don't go to her oh
come on i don't go to the
to the to the commission meetings i'm
number two they say you know chin you're
too high profile
with that bad throat but all that stuff
if they see you walking in they'll know
what we're having the meetings
he is so [ __ ] off base with that
whole conversation it's incredible
first of all i knew and i had a dozen
serious meetings with chin
he was extremely smart
extremely smart
he was number two
under fat tony for one reason the boss
before fat tony who died
i can't think of his [ __ ] name but it
doesn't matter he me he brought in chen
chen was
the gangster part of that he brought in
chip and he says i'm gonna make fat tony
the boss
it's my decision
i want you to promise me you don't kill
him
be his number two
and
time you'll become number one
promise me
tim promised him he allowed that to
happen
chim was five times more vicious
smarter
in every way had a bigger following than
fat tone
tony i loved him he was a great guy
um
so that's the way it felt so he's wrong
and then
i went to commission meetings
i was there just for security when chin
fat tony came
and uh
paul was there there's even a tape of
that meeting
when guys are coming out of the house
not inside or anything like that but
anyway
then he told frantoni it's time for you
to step down
and he stepped down
and chin was number one
and i was at those commission meetings
with john
even after paul which in
and benny eggs was his underboss so he
don't know what the [ __ ] he's talking
about at all
and he wasn't stupid
he did this little scam
and he put himself in and out of
hospitals so that when they call
when he when he's indicted
and they call doctors and things and
that he
he's beated for years he doesn't
understand so you can't charge a man who
doesn't understand what the charges are
what it is he's mentally insane he
played that
in my opinion that's the only thing i
didn't like about chin
he played that too much one time
agents came to his house he ran upstairs
he got it naked under the shower with an
umbrella with his mother
you do that in front of your mother it's
a little excessive
for me and if you're not bothered by
going to prison
then take your billions or millions
whatever he had and leave the mafia [ __ ]
them off you'll walk away
with your money
somewhere along the line you have to
have a little bit more integrity
when
my lawyer
went on a visit where he was in texas
after he was convicted
my lawyer was representing somebody
and he in the room
and chin
had already been convicted he came out
he was talking perfect
on his visits and everything else
because they found him guilty that they
matter no more
he's talking perfect so my lawyer says
sami is that crazy oh he was talking
perfect
i heard him the whole time
i said i know it was an act so i don't
even know what he's saying
so he's absolutely wrong and i and i can
give you story after story
which i'm not going to give you
right now
of meetings i have with him that are
important some of them are on my podcast
um he was the sharpest attack
and i don't know anybody
anybody in the mafia who would have said
[ __ ] me [ __ ] him
he will kill you in a second
flat
no hesitation whatever
none
everybody under him loved him
just
chin yes bobby manner
benny eggs all of them
loved him and he had ran a tight ship
and a tight family
so
he's totally wrong
and
so all you people who love him
when he talks like that doesn't know
what he's talking about
i would like for me and him to go to a
doctor together
so i can get my foot out of his ass
because it would take a few
doctors rudy my foot would fit perfect
in his ass tony and eight and a half can
you show us what that would look like
with gerard right now just so we get a
an actual glimpse no no
something like that would actually go
down the show
wow
i gotta take uh
yeah we got two minutes left to wrap
yeah we're going to do it yeah we gotta
take it we're gonna take a break to wrap
up here uh uh four minutes left so one
question i asked i don't know who this
conversation came up it may have been
with chess palmentary that we talked
about we've done a lot of different
things that uh have you have you had any
conversations or talks with junior at
all
who's joe gotti jr
no
no no talks no
you know what the world would be curious
to see it'd be very interesting if the
two of you guys had to sit down and i
know you would never do it i know you
would no no no i'm not interested in
sitting down with him see michael was a
different story i don't hate i didn't
even when i didn't get along with
michael i didn't hate him
i think that he said certain things that
were not true about me about john about
a few things that he said i saw him now
in a new one
where he was walking up and down my chin
in the bathrobe
before that
and chen told them if junior knows he'll
make you a captain i'll make you one of
my family
makes sense okay yeah we don't even want
to talk about that
didn't have nobody come near him
there was a main guy in the colombo
family
who
used his name
giganti
he had him called then he was this close
this guy to get killed because he used
his name
so
he wasn't the boss
it was a powerhouse
i mean and he was tough but he was
pretty fair in different ways
i mean i had a couple of good decisions
and one of the decisions is
he
there was a whole hit it's a long story
i'm not going to get into it but when at
the end he called me down again for a
final meeting
and i had permission to whack a few
people and he said i want you to do me a
favor two of these kids
that
you could hurt
belong to a friend of ours
we took him out
we take care of his wife and those kids
i want to ask you for a favor give them
a pass they were that wrong that he had
his
and i said okay
i will do that but i want to ask you for
a favor
he was a boss
i was just the
pup
acting captain
he said what
i said this kid's capacity who gave me
all this information and caused this
whole thing he's with you people
i know now that you know this whole
thing
you're gonna wind up killing him because
he came to us and not use
he created this
what do you want i want you to give him
a pass
he saved my life this kid
i'll give him give him a pass and i'll
give those two kids you want to piss
that's pretty smart tammy he put his
hand out when he shook hands
and nobody got killed
and after that
so and it's a whole long story
and you can't see that on patrick's
interview he's gonna see it on my
podcast
we're gonna put hey don't you put his
link below for his podcast so people can
go subscribe gang if you enjoyed today's
podcast give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel mafia states of
america
what's that absolutely for sammy what's
the oh the what oh we got sammy yes
that's right so we got a merch
if you're team sammy
we have sammy's shirts up here now can
you put up the link kai sammy this is
for you team gravano right now we have a
team gravano going on we have a team
francie's going on
if you're team gravano go order team
garvano's shirt kai put the link below
so people can go
order team gravano people are asking
when is mafia states of america going to
come up come out here here's how it's
going to work out it's either going to
come out
in q4 of 2021 or it's going to come out
in 2022 but it's eventually going to
come out okay when we make that
announcement i'm sure the world's going
to go crazy lots of people are upset
when i say 2022 but we're working on it
we're finalizing it today you're going
to get a sneak peek of some of the stuff
that we're doing which is going to be
exciting but we're looking forward to
launching that to the world sammy great
and i want to tell the people who are
watching over here listen it's going to
come out in 2021
do you want to
amend your statement at all that could
be by the way
i think it's safe to say it's coming out
in 2021 that could be october 1st but
that could also be december 31st
but it's happening in q4 2021 and fbi if
you're listening to this that was a
trend
take care everybody we'll see you on
thursday take care sammy all right bye
bye bye bye this was great
you